[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى نقاش اليوم من فضلك من باريس
مشاهدينا مونديال كره القدم لعمل 2022
ينطلقوا هذا الاحد مونديال تصادفه لاول
مره دوله عربيه دوله قطر دوله سالت الحبر
وثره النقاشه بشانها منذ ان فازت بحق
استضافه هذا الموعد الكروي الذي يشد
انتباه الملايين عبر العالم وكل ما اقترب
موعد
في اوروبا بالتحديد لمقاطعه هذا الحدث على
خلفيه اتهامات بالفساد وسجل الدوحه في
مجال الحريات وحقوق الانسان في مقابل من
يدافع عن قطر واستضافتها للمونديال معتبرا
ان هذه الانتقادات ما هي الا حمله مضلله
تريد استهداف قطر مباشره
حمل اتهموا فيها اطراف غربيه وعربيه
نفتح النقاش المشاهدين اليوم مع ضيوفنا
ابدا بضيفنا هنا في الاسديو السيد همم
محمد مندور الناقد والصحفيه رياضي شكرا
على قبول السيد محمد اهلا بك من الدوحه
السيد عبد الله يوسف الملا رئيس نادي
الاهلي في قطر اهلا وسهلا بك وشكرا على
قبول دعوات سيد عبد الله يوسف المولى
ومن لندن ينضم الينا الصحفي والكاتب
السياسي سيد حميد الكفائي مرحبا بك شكرا
على قبول الدعوه ابدا
بالضيفنا من قطر لاننا نتحدث عن قطر اساله
مباشره السيد عبد الله يوسف الملا ااه ما
الذي يحدث لماذا كل صباح منذ اكثر من شهر
ااا عندما اصحوا صباحا اشرب القهوه وابدا
اقرا
المواقعت الصفحه المواقع لا اجد الا
الاخبار الخاصه بحقوق الانسان همم في همم
قطر وضع العماله الاجنبيه ما الذي يحدث
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الكرام في هذه الحلقه واتمنى ان ان تكون
هذه الحلقه حلقه يعني ثريه بالحقائق
الحقيقه التي نستطيع من خلالها ان نرد على
كل من ايه يعني يحاول ان
يقلل من شيء من شان استضافه خطر لبطوله
كاس العالم والتي تفصلنا اقل من ثلاثه
ايام همم الانطلاق هذا العرس العالمي
والذي يتطلع له في جميع ارجاء المعموره
الحقيقه يعني همم هذا الكلام مردود عليه
والان المفروض كان هذا الكلام يكون قبل 12
عام وليس قبل ثلاثه ايام فقط عن انطلاق
الحدث وقطع وسجل قطر الحقيقه همم سجل نظيف
جدا فيما يتعلق بالعماله وهناك العديد من
الحقائق في هذا همم
المجال وهو ان اكثر من 10,000 عاملوا خلال
تلك الفتره في انشاء هذه الملاعب
الموندياليه التي اصبحت اليوم جاهزه
لاستضافه الحدث همم يعني هناك من يحارب
النجاح هناك من يرمي الشجره المثمره ل-
همم في في يعني في في هذا العالم الحقيقي
وبدون الرجوع وبدون الاستناد الى الى ادله
داغه ومن لديه الادله الدم عليه ان ان
يعني يوضح
للمشاهد ولكن ان ان ترمي جزافا شمالا
وجنوبا بدون
دليل
بما ذكر كيف تفسر اذا مؤخرا كثره التقارير
الحقوقيه عن قطر
التقارير الاعلاميه وما همم يكتب خاصه هنا
في فرنسا والصحف الاوروبيه بشكل عام
لماذا في رايك اخي العزيز كل ما كتب في
الصحافه الفرنسيه والصحافه الاوروبيه هذه
عنصريه مبطنه هذه عنصريه مبطنه ونحن طبعا
لا نلتفت لها لان احنا على بعد امتار من
انطلاق الحدث ومعنى شريك الاتحاد الدولي
لكره القدم ومعنا اكثر من 120 هيئه سياسيه
في قطر تتابع كل ما يتعلق كل صغير وكبير
في ما يخص هذا المونديال الذي اصبح يعني
اا الاوروبيون يغيرون من ما وصلت اليه قطر
وقطر رفعت مستوى التنظيم ومستوى الاداء في
هذه البطوله والذي سوف يشهدها هذا العالم
يعني خلال ثلاثه ايام من الان وانا اكد لك
من خلال هذه الشاشه ومن شاشتكم همم
الكريمه بان قطر
البياض ولا ننظر الى الخلف ومن لديه اي
تقرير همم طبعا كان منظمات همم انسانيه
فعليهم ان يثبتوا ذلك ولكن ان يرموا التهم
بدون وجه حق فهذا طبعا نرفضه رفضا باتا
وكذلك همم كما ذكر سمو الامير وكما ذكر
نائب رئيس مجلس الوزراء وزير الخارجيه بان
عندما تكون المصالح الاقتصاديه قطر هي
الارواح قطر هي البلد لما تاتي النقطه
همم
سيد حميد الكيفائي في رايك انت توافق
ضيفنا من الدوحه على ما يقولها او لك
تفسيرنا اخر لماذا كثرت التقارير عن قطر
مؤخرا عن حقوق العماله في قطر عن حقوق
الممنوحه والحريات الفرديه والعامه في
دوله قطر كل ما اقترب موعد المونديال كل
ما كثرت الكتابه والتقارير التي تصدر عن
هذه الدوله الخليجيه
تحيه لك ولي والضيف من قطر والضيفك
فالاستهلا المشاهدين طبعا
يعني المونديال حدث مهم جدا في العالم كما
يعرف الجميع
لذلك فان هذا الاهتمام العالمي بالمونديال
في قطر هو مبرر فهذا حدثا عالمي يهتم به
كل الناس كل العالم همم في المونديال
السابق في موسكو
شاهده ثلاثه مليارات و500 كل كل التقارير
التي كانت تكتب في المونديال روسيا مثلا
كانت عن الرياضه عن الملاعب التي ستستضيف
الفرق عن من سيحضر من سيغيب عن الطقس لكن
لم نقرا كثيرا عن مونديال روسيا وسجل
روسيا في حقوق الانسان هذاك
نعم همم انا جايك على هذا الموضوع
في ما يخص قطر قطر هي تصدق لان
تستضيف هذا الحدث العالمي المهم وكان
عليها ان تنسجم مع المجتمع الدولي تنسجن
مع القوانين الدوليه
وتراعي هذه المساله قطر ارادت ان تروج
لنفسها وبالتاكيد حصولها همم ان حصولها
على موافقه الفيفا في ان همم تجرى يجرى
كاس العالم تصفيات كاس العالم في قطر كان
انتصارا وكان انجازا تفتخر به قطر ومن
حقها ان تفعل ذلك ولكن كان عليها منذ عام
2010 حتى الان ان تنسجم وتعد القوانين كي
تنسى المعلومات
حقوق العمال الاجانب هذه مساله اثيره مرات
مرات عديده
وهنا كتقرير لجريده الجارديان الرصينه
المهنيه المحترمه قال ان ان
6500 عام الاجنبي
مات في قطر منذ عام 2010 حتى الان وهذه
الاحصائيات ليست من
مؤامره تحافظ قطر وانما هي احصائيات
اخذت من الهند رسميا من الهند وبنجلاديش
وسريلانكا وباكستان ويقال ان العدد اكبر
هناك همم قضيه حقوق الانسان قضيه مهمه جدا
والرياضه هدف الرياضه الاساسي هو همم رفعت
علاء حقوق الانسان اعلاق السلام والامن
والود بين الشعوب لذلك كنا نتمنى ان ترتقي
قطر الى مستوى الدول العالميه التي تستضيف
مثل هذه الاحداث
عرب بالتاكيد نفرح عندما تكون دوله عربيه
بهذا المستوى وتستضيف المونديال ولكن كان
يجب عليها ان تتخذ الاجراءات المناسبه
التي ترتقي الى مستوى الحدث المونديال حدث
دوليا مهم وكان يجب على قطر وعلى حكومه
قطر ان ان تعدل القوانين وان همم تستقبل
هذه الانتقادات بروح رياضيه وان تعمل ما
في وسعها كيف تنسجن على المجتمع الدولي
ومعالم منظمات الحقوقيه لا ان ترفض هذه
التقارير وتقول انها مؤامره وانهم اعداء
النجاح هذه المنظمات الحقوقيه ليس لها
ثائر مع قطر ابدا بالتاكيد
النجاح في الرياضه شيء شيء همم
كل المنظمات الحقوقيه والناس جميعا
يؤيدونه بل ينتصرون له هذه تقارير حقيقيه
وهذه الانتقادات انتقادات وجيهه وكان يجب
على قطر ان تستقبلها ويجب عليها الان ايضا
ان تستجيب لهذه الضغوط وهي من منظمات
حقوقيه منظمات حقوق انسان
وليست من دول منافسه لقطر او دول معاديه
لقطر ابدا
طيب همم اعلم سيد عبد الله يوسف المولى
انك تريد ان تعاقب سعودي اليك همم السيد
همم محمد مندور انت ناقد والصحفي الرياضي
كيف تفسر ان مونديال قطر هذه المره
التركيز فيه في وسائل الاعلام العالميه
همم هي عن حقوق الانسان عن وضع العمال ما
بين من يؤكد
من ينفي ومن يقول ان المونديال هذه المره
سويس بشكل كبير
الاول مساء الخير عليك وعلى كل المشاهدين
مساء الخير على الاستاذ حميد مساء الخير
على استاذ عبد الله رئيس نادي العميد
القطري اللي انا شخصيا بحترمه جدا وبقدره
عايز اتكلم في النقطه دي لان النقطه دي
مهمه جدا
ومثيره للجدل
لماذا لم اول هنرجع شويه سنين وراء لماذا
لم يتحدث الجميع حين نظمت الصين دوره
الالعاب الاولمبيه في بكين عام 2008 وكان
هناك انتهاكات صواريخها لحقوق العمال كان
هناك انتهاكات كبيره جدا
لم تكن لم تكن بهذا الشكل همم تثار لانه
يمكن لان المونديال همم المونديال كره
القدم همم يثير انتباه الملايين اكثر من
الالعاب الاخرى اكيد لكن دي دوره الالعاب
الاولمبيه لكن الامر هنا لا يتعلق بقطر
ولكن يتعلق بقوه الدوله التي يتعامل معها
المجتمع الدولي احنا نعلم جميعا ان الصين
دوله قويه لن يستطيع الغرب التعامل معها
بنفس نبره وبنفس الحته وبنفس القصوه التي
يتعامل بها مع قطر لذلك فالنبره كانت
خافته هناك بعض الانتقادات للصين بعض
الانتقادات الخفيفه للبرازيل في عام 2014
حين نظمت همم المونديال وقتها خرجت
مظاهرات كبيره جدا اعتراضا اساسا على
التنظيم وتم التعامل معها حتى انه تم قتل
المتظاهرين انفسهم من الشرطه البرازيليه
ولم يتحرك المجتمع الدولي لم يتحرك احد
ولم يتحدث احد عن حقوق الانسان وانا حقوق
العمال مثل هذه الاشياء الا في تقارير
خفيفه في بعض الصحف التي اذا كيف تفسر
تفسر ذلك انه اخيرا انا اعتبر اعتبر ان
هذا غيره من قطر كيف لا هذه الدوله
الصغيره نعم كيف لهذه الدوله الصغيره حجما
التي تمتلك ما شاء الله كل هذه الاموال
والغاز
[موسيقى]
الاوروبيه قطر قطر هي من دعمت نفسها في
الفوز بكاس في الفوز بتنظيم كاس العالم لو
نرى حاليا
اعضاء مكتب تنفيذي في الاتحاد الدولي هم
نقعته قطر هذه هذا التنظيم وهذا لم ياتي
من فراغ اتى بسبب ملف قوي بسبب ما ما
تفعله قطر على الارض الواقع حاليا ملاعب
كبيره ملاعب ستتحول الى مدارس
وجامعات واشياء كثيره جدا ستفعلها قطر
ملاعب ستتفكك وستهدا الى دول الفقيره
اشياء فعلتها قطر اجبرت المجتمع الدولي
اجبرت الفيفا اجبرت الجميع على احترام
ملفها وبالتالي اعت اه همم هذا الامر
انها فرصه لقطر مثلا ان ترقي من قوانينها
الخاصه بها الانسان والعمال
لا لما نيجي ننظر لا ملف قطر في حقوق
العمال انا لم ارى على مدار السنوات
الماضيه اي عامل على الاقل مصري من وانا
مصري واعلم ان هناك مئات الالاف من
المصريين العاملين في قطر لم يشتكي احد من
قطر لم يشتكي احد ان له اموال في قطر لم
يتقاضاه لم يشتكي احد انه يعامل معامله
سيئه في قطر على عكس كده الدول الخارجيه
الاخرى التي لا نريد ذكر اسمها هي بشكل
عام اعتقارير همم عن العمل التطال كل دول
الخليج من بينها قطر
والخا الخاصه بحقوق السيد السيد عبد الله
يوسف همم المله لماذا لا تغتدم همم قطر
مثلا مثل ما قال السيد الكفائي همم هذا
النقاش الحاصل حول الحقوق الحريات ان
تستفيد منها قطر
توقع اكثر بين هلالين مثل ما يقولون
المنتقدون لقطر في مساله حقوق الانسان
بالمقارنه مع جيرانها الذين ايضا ينتقدون
في هذه المسائل
همم انا طبعا راح اجاوبك على من خلال يعني
ما يخص قطر واترك الدول الاخرى يعني
بامكانكم توجيه السؤال لهم ولكن بقول لك
بكل امانه همم فيما يتعلق يعني قطر يعني
استمعت الى العديد من الانتقادات العديد
من النصائح وناخذ بها ما يمنع اذا كان
النقد بناء نحن نستمع اليه واقول لك يعني
في هذا في هذا الخصوص همم يعني الاتحاد
الدولي النقابات العمال طبعا ثمن كل ما
قدمته قطر من تغييرات في القوانين همم ما
يخص العمال فيما الفيفا في عده تصاريح
طلعت هي اعلى سلطه والمشرفه على على هذه
البطوله هي طبعا تحادات الدوليه يعني حميد
لا تجامل نحن همم صرفنا يعني بطولات في
العاب القوه البطولات الصلاه بطولات همم
ما الذي صارت الكبرى عفوا في 2019 وحصلنا
على الشهادات من الصحفيين وليس من الاتحاد
الدولي الفيفا قد يعني تقول ان قطر احرزت
تقدما كبيرا خلال القوانين وتحسين الرواتب
وظروف المعيشه هناك احصائيات تم يعني
اخذها ويعمل احصائيات الاخوان في وزاره
العمل اكثر من 86% من العمال الاكد وان
اصلاحات العمال اثرت ايجابي عليهم هناك
ثمانيه
98% نسبه العمال الذي اكدوا ان استلام
رواتبهم في الاوقات المحدده هناك قوانين
بما يتعلق همم نقل الكفالات انتهت ولا له
وجود كل هذه التصريحات وكل هذه الاصلاحات
التي قدمتها قطر تقابل يعني همم
ايجابيه ويعني جحاف حق قطر في تنظيم بطوله
مثل بطوله العالم يعني
اعرف من نور في تنظيم البطوله وراح ان شاء
الله راح تكون خلال ثلاثه ايام دليل
القاطع اللي على هذا الكلام اللي اقوله لك
هناك اكثر من 10,000 جوله تفتيشيه من
وزاره العمل هناك منظمه العمل الدوليه لها
مكتب في قطر يعني همم يعني تساهم وتتابع
ضمان حقوق العمال وعلى راس اولويات الدوله
هذه منظمه العمل الدوليه هناك النقابات
يعني همم بكل امانه يقول حق الاستاذ حميد
يا ريتك انت جئت الدوحه وتطلع على هذه
الوقائع لا تستمع الى احصائيات والى
تقارير يعني مثلا
استمع اليك وانظر الى احصائيات قدمتها
مؤسسات عريقه همم ونقلتها من بينها همم بي
بي سي وايضا همم
لديك منظمه العمل الدوليه التي تتحدث عن
عدد همم العمال الاجانب الذين لقوا حتفهم
منذ قطر في بناء الملاعب منظمه العمل
الدوليه تتحدث عن 50 عاما
سيناء عام
1900 اخرين همم في عام 2021 لواحده بينما
37,600 اخرين بجراح خفيفه الى متوسطه
وتقارير اخرى تتحدث من بين تقرير تابعه ل-
همم لمنظمته
التي تتهم الشركات القطريه باتباع نظام
العماله القسريه اي الصخري مرتك على ذلك
ان هناك عدد من اما لم يتلقى وجورهم او
همم حتى انهم منعوا من مغادره قطر للعوده
الى بنجلاديش او باكستان او الى الهند اخي
العزيز
اخ رفيق هذا الكلام مردود عليه والدليل
على ذلك اقول لك ان في مكتب لمنظمه العمل
الدوليه في قطر هل هي تغض النظر عن هذا
الشيء هل هناك 120 هيئه سياسيه دبلوماسيه
في قطر هل تعتقد ان عملها تاكل وتشرب ولا
تتابع كل هذه الامور هل تسمح لي ان اقرا
الاحصائيات التي انا لدي الله يطول عمرك
بالنسبه لي ايه شوف انا بقول لك يعني
الاحصائيات همم في ملاعب المونديال
الثمانيه يعني في استاد البيت الذي سوف
يفتتح ان شاء الله بعد ثلاثه ايام في عدد
يعني العمال اللي فيه 798 عاملا في الموقع
73 مليون ساعه عمل كامله 420 عمليه تفتيش
ميدانيه استاد استاد الوسيل
3852 وهذا راح يقام فيه ان شاء الله
الختام اكثر من 3852 عامل 49 مليون عدد
ساعات 159 عمليه تفتيشيه هذه من الملاعب
الكبيره يا اخي ثمان ثمان ملاعب يا اخي
لازم يكون في بعض الاحداث يعني الكمال لله
الكمال لله ولكن لازم تكون في اصابات لازم
تكون كده لكن العدد سته الاف مبالغ فيه
وانا اتحدى اي شخص او منظمه العمل الدوليه
هذه اللي تقول لك عندها 6000 الاف او
حكومه يوم الريس واتش خليها تجيب التقارير
وتجيب واحد يعني انا اكد لك من هذه الشاشه
ومن ممباركم ان هذا الكلام مبالغ فيه وهو
فقط غيره لا اكثر ولا اقل دوله صغيره
استطاعت ان تبهر العالم همم
المطلوبه في الملف قبل عام من انطلاق
الحدث وتفضل استاذ تحياتي حميد
الكفائي هناك من يرى ان قطر بالمقارنه مع
الدول الخليجيه الاخرى حتى قبل سنوات رضت
لما تطالبه منظمات حقوقيه مثلا الغت نظام
الكفاله للعمال وهذا النظام لا زال موجود
في عدد من الدول الخليجيه الاخرى
قارن مع الدول الاخرى الدول الاخرى لم
تتصدى لان تستضيف المونديال يعني همم نحن
فقط
في الازمه الخارجيه كانت من بين مطالبها
ان تتقاسم مع قطر استضافه
المونديال المقبل ستقاسمه الولايات
المتحده وكندا
فقط على هذه على المقارنه عندما قلت لي لا
نقارن مع الدول
[موسيقى]
انه نحن نتحدث
على فكره هو نفس النقاش على فكره اكيد
سيفتح ايضا مع مع احتضان المملكه العربيه
السعوديه للالعاب الشتويه
بالتاكيد هناك منظمات سوف تطرح القضايا
التي تتعلق بحقوق الانسان وحقوق العمل اما
القول انه هذه غيره من قطار او ان هناك من
يحسد قطر هذا كلام غير صحيح وغير علمي
وغير واقعي ننظر الى التقارير تقارير
منظمات محترمه
انظر الى ما قاله مصطفى قادري من منظمه
اكودم للاستشارات
وللابحاث في مجال الاعمال وهي منظمه دوليه
محترمه قال ان كاس العالم
يبنى على اساس العبوديه الجديده هذا ما
قاله مصطفى قادر منظمه منظمات حقوق
الانسان رياضيون من مختلف انحاء العالم
بينهم دعني اذكر اسم
رياض البريطاني المعروف والمعلق الرياضي
رفضوا ان يذهبوا الى قطر بسبب هذه
الانتهاكات او بسبب عدم اقناع قطر لهذه
الدول لهذه المنظمات بانها فعلا
قامت بما يجب عليها ان تفعله من تقديم
الحقوق ومن حمايه هؤلاء العمال الاجانب
وكذلك باقي القوانين التي يجب ان تنسجم
على
الحدث الرياضي نحن نتحدث عن الرياضه
انت لا تتحدث عن نقطه همه اريد ان اثيرها
معك سيد الكفائي حدث رياضي ونحن نعلم جيدا
ان هذا الحدث الرياضي عدد كبير من الدول
تريد تنظيمه وكل دوله لديها اهداف اهداف
اقتصاديه اهداف خاصه باظهار القوه السوفت
باور القوه الناعمه للدوله وكل ال ال ال
التنظيمات الخاصه العاب نعرف ان ان لديها
رهانات بالدوله التي تنظمها وتعطي هاله
لدوله التي تنظمها ما رايك فيما قاله
اليوم الرئيس الفرنسي عندما قال لا يجب
تسييس مونديال قطر عندما طرح عليه سؤال
بشان ملف حقوق الانسان والحريات في قطر
بالتزامن مع المونديال
نعم لا يجب ان لا تسيس هذه القضايا وهي
غير مسيسه ولكن لا يمكن ان نبعد الرياضه
عن حقوق الانسان الرياضه هدف الرياضه هو
يعني
مستحيل الانجليزي
لا يمكن لنا ان نبعد سياسه عن الرياضه
ومخالفات للقانون الدولي لا نتحدث عن
السياسه نعم الرئيس الفرنسي والرئيس
الوزراء البريطانيا ورئيس الامريكي هؤلاء
همم قوي قوي
سياسيون وهم يريدون ان يقيموا علاقات مع
قطر ومع غيرها لذلك هم لا يرغبون ولا
يريدون لمثل هذه الامور ان تطرح ولكن هذه
مناسبه مهمه يجب ان تطرح فيها مثل هذه
القضايا التي يهتم لها العالم اهتم لها
العالم
وتهتم لها المؤسسات الرياضيه يهتم لها
الرياضيون والفنانين والمثقفون
والاكاديميون والمحامون هذه قضايا في غايه
الاهميه ان ارادت قطر ان تحسن من صورتها
عليها ان تلبي وانت تستجيب لمثل هذه
الدعوات
كنت معي في برنامج نقاش وبرامج سابقه
وتحدثنا في مواضيع سياسيه عديده في
المنطقه انت تعرف همم اكثر مني ان ااه
المنطقه العربيه هناك مشاحنات هناك خلافات
واي فرصه همم وخلافات
منافسات اقليميه تنافس اقليمي ما بين
القوه في هذه المنطقه هناك من يقول ان هذا
الملف حقا اريد به باطل ملف حقوق الانسان
والحريات ما هو الا ملف يتم الضغط به على
قطر او ضربها من قبل اعدائها ومنافسها في
المنطقه او خارجها
الدول العربيه غير معنيه بهذه المساله نحن
نتحدث عن المنظمات حقوق الانسان الدوليه
وليس الدول العربيه والدول العربيه
بالتاكيد لديها مشاكل مع قطر لان قطر تدعم
الاخوان المسلمين وهذا شيء معروف والدول
العربيه معظمها تدرج هذه المجموعه ضمن
المنظمات الارهابيه فهذا الخلاف
وليس كل الدول العربيه استاذ حميد استاذ
حميد استاذ حميد عفوا عفوا اتمنى
النقاش من خلال تاسيس الرياضه ولا تدخل في
نقاشات لان اذا فتحت الباب راح يكون الباب
صعب انك تغلقها الله يسلمك لذلك خليك في
مجال للرياضه وين وين حقوق الانسان في همم
فرنسا في نهائي ابطال الدوري
الفرنسيه
اين حقوق عندما سقط همم سقف ملعب ماراكانا
على العمال في 2014 الاعلام الغربي يعني
لم ينطق ولو بكلمه واحده احنا احنا واقفين
منها
حقوق الانسان
كلها كلها سياسيه
المقدم البرنامج للاستاذ رفيق هو الذي قال
هناك قضايا سياسيه بين قطر والدول العربيه
وهذا هو انا طرحتها سؤال من باب انه هناك
من يقول ان هذه الملفات هي ورقه ضغط حتى
من قبل عفوا اتم فقط انها وهذا راي سائد
على فكره موجود ايضا منتشر في همم البلدان
العربيه ان حتى الغرب همم
اريد به باطن عندما يريد ان يضغط على
الدوله يستخدم ملف حقوق الانسان بعض همم
قطاع في راي العام في المنطقه العربيه
يعتقد ذلك انه عندما نريد همم دوله همم
غربيه تريد ان تضغط تخ هذا الملف لكن في
الجانب الاخر تبيعها همم تبيعها الطائرات
الحربيه من الرافال وطائرات الامريكيه دون
ان يكون هناك حديث عن حقوق الانسان من هذا
الباب سالت سؤالي نعم
فيما يخص همم يعني نحن لدينا نقطه ضعف في
العالم العربي ويحقوق الانسان يجب ان
نتحرر من هذه همم من هذا الضعف يجب ان
نعطي الناس حقوقها يجب ان ننتقل الحريات
هذه مساله سوف تثار دائما ضدنا ان بقينا
نتحفظ على
مساله حقوق الانسان حقوق الانسان همم الان
اصبحت في غايه الاهميه في العالم لذلك يجب
ان نتخذ اجراءات يجب ان تتخذ الدول خصوصا
مثل قطر التي تتصدى لاستضافه المونديال
همم يجب ان تتخذ اجراءات في مجال حقوق
الانسان والا سوف نبقى
نعم في كل مره
يعني يحصل حدث رياضي او فني او اقتصادي في
عالمنا سوف تثار هذه القضايا اا اما انه
الخلافات بين الدول العربيه فلها همم مجال
اخر يمكننا ان نتحدث عنها وكما قلت هناك
خلافات مع قطر وقطر همم غير منسجمه حتى مع
دول الخليج العربي التي هي جزء من
اخر هذا نقاش اخر
الخليجي لكن غير مستجمه هذا موقف الاطراف
السياسه ونحن برنامجنا الرياضي برنامجنا
الرياضي استاذ حميد تدخل في الرياضه لانه
لا لا
استاذ رفيق طال عمرك
يعني معامله همم قبل ما يكون عامل هو
انسان
حقوق الانسان منظمات تباع وتشترط العمر
عمرك
طبعا همم
ليس نقاش فقط
واريد
همم
السيد همم محمد همم
الالعاب هذه الجميع يتحدث ويقول انها تحدث
رياضي لكن منذ زمن بعيد ليس فقط المونديال
حتى الالعاب همم الالعاب الالعاب
الاولمبيه منذ الحرب العالميه الثانيه
فيها هناك انظمه سلطويه تريد ان تروج همم
عكس ذلك ونتذكر الكثير هناك الكثير من
الامثله لماذا كره القدم بالتحديد اخذت
هذه الهاله فصار رجال الاعمال يستثمرون
فيها الدول الكبرى ودول تريد ان تجد لها
مكان انت تستمر فيها بشكل كبير وايضا يتم
اغتنام الفرصه همم بهذا الموعد المونديال
لاثاره مساء المهمه مثل مساء الحقوق
الانسان والحريات انا هاجاوبك طبعا على
السؤال ده لكن قبل ما اجاوب بس عندي نقطه
صغيره ااه عايز ارد به على اساس حميد هي
نقطه الخاصه بمثلا على سبيل المثال جاري
لينكار ولماذا لن يذهب الى قطر نعم وانا
اعتقد ان جاري لينيكر بعد اربع سنوات من
الان سيكون على راس المتوجدين داخل
الولايات المتحده لحضور مباريات كاس
العالم فعايزين نضع هذا الامر بين قوسين
ونرى هل الشخص العراقي والانسان الافغاني
وبعد اليمنيين والاخرين من الذين اختلتهم
امريكا وفعلت بهم ما فعلت هل ليس لهم حقوق
اكيد لهم حقوق فلماذا الان لا يلت- لن
يلتفت احد الى امريكا لن ينتقد احد امريكا
وسيذهب الجميع
وسستمتعون
هذه الحجه مردوده عفوا عفوا سعود
مهمه اريد جميعا هناك نقطه مهمه هناك من
يقول ان هذه الحجه مردوده لان الحق يبقى
حق لا يعني انه لم يتحدث عنه فلان عندما
نظم مثلا في البرازيل وروسيا لا يعني ان
الحقنه في روسيا يجب ان نسكت عليه في مكان
اخر يبقى حق اذا تحدث عنه شخص بميزان واحد
مع الجميع وليس مثل الترزي او الخياط الذي
يقيس طول وعرض الشخص ليفصل له عقل على
مقاسه ده نقطه نقطه مهمه جدا عايز اتكلم
فيها النقطه الاخرى اللي هي سؤال حضرتك
لماذا يستثمر الجميع في كره القدم ولماذا
يتحدث
الدوليه لكره القدم بانها تسييس ايضا همم
تسيس ايضا همم
الرياضه اخر تصريحات همم للمسؤولين في
الفيفا همم السابقون قالوا مثلا عندما
منحه المونديال لروسيا همم منحه لروسيا من
هنا ومنحه ايضا منه هناك للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هناك حسابات جيو سياسيه
واستراتيجيه حتى داخل للفيفا هو الحياه
الحقيقه الامر كله مسيس لكن هم لا يتحدثوا
عن السياسه الا حين يريدون همم اذا همم هم
يرفضوا تماما تاسيس الرياضه وتسييس كره
القدم تحديدا لكنهم يحتفظوا لانفسهم
بالتدخل وقت ما يشاء همم راينا ذلك حين
حدثت الحرب من الروسيه الاوكرانيه وكلنا
ضد الحرب وكلنا مع حقوق الانسان وحقول لنا
ضد الاغتيال السوفيتي لبعض الاخرانيين
والتدخل في سياسات الدوله كلنا عنانا ونحن
العرب علينا من الحروب اكثر من غيرنا بشكل
كبير فلذلك همم نرفض تماما كل هذا الامر
لكن يتم استثمار هذه الحرب في كره القدم
بمنع المنتخب الروسي بمنع همم جميع
الالعاب الروسيه
المونديال باقصاء روسيا اصلا همم
همم رجال اعمال المنتمين لكره القدم سواء
رومانا برافو فيتش او اشير عثمانوف من
اموالهم ومن ملكيتهم لبعض الانديه
والاحتفاظ بها هناك اشياء كثيره حتى القطط
الروسيه منعت من المشاركه في التظاهرات
وفي المعارض تحت حجه الحرب الروسيه فلذلك
هم يحتفظوا لانفسهم ببعض الامور التي
يحتاجوها اذا ارادوا التدخل وانا ازعم انه
لو هناك سيحدث داخل المباريات القادمه في
كاس العالم سيحدث تدخل سياسي معين طيب
اعتمد على كفايه العرب لو لو كانت الحقوق
والحريات ملفا غير ضعيف ونقطه همم نقطه
الضعف في بلدان الى العربيه همم لا
يستخدمها غيرك في ضربه كبها لماذا لا يتم
اذن الاهتمام بهذه النقطه كي لا تستخدم
يعني الحقيقه الكلام ده مردود عليه بشكل
كبير جدا والكلام ده يحتاج اوقات كثيره
لكن اذا كان هناك اشياء سيئه في الوطن
العربي ونحن جميعا فقط
تم زرعها داخل الوطن العربي والمسؤول عنها
والمسؤول عن زرعها هم انفسهم هم الذين
ينتقدون حقوق الانسان في هذه الدول فاذا
ازرع ديكتاتور ثم اتي بعدها بعده سنوات
لانتقد حقوق الانسان التي يفعلها هذا
الديكتاتور داخل الوطن اشياء رهيبه بصراحه
يوم العيد
انت انت تقوم بعملي سيد الكفايه اليوم انا
ساعود اليك ساعود اليك بعد قليل سويتش
تقوم بزرعه ديكتاتوريه هي اصلا تنتقل هي
اصلا
هنا في فرنسا
يمكن ان ترفع قضيه وتتابع قضائيا همم حتى
الشرطه لا يمكن ان تدخلها الى السجن الى
تجاوزت حدودها
واستخدام وقد استخدمت القوه المفرطه
الاعلام وهنا داخل فرنسا تتحدث همم عن هذا
الموضوع وتنتقد حتى داخل القبه
محيده لها ما لها والهم عليها وانا لا
تتحدث عنها تحدث عن الحكومات عن السياسيين
عن بعض ال- ال- الاشخاص الذين يتحدثون
بغير سلطه تتحدث عن قوه غربيه
احنا نتعامل مع انظمه
المدير الفني لمنتخب الالماني لكره القدم
همم يتحدث عن انه اذا فازت المانيا وان
شاء الله لن تفوز بالبطوله لن نحتفل ههه
لن نحتفل بالبطوله على ارض قطر وسنحتفل
بها في المانيا يا اخي ده انت كنت موجود
في 2014 كمساعد للمدير الفني هو كيم اوف
وحدث ما حدث في البرازيل من قتل وسلب ونهب
وهمم واختيالات لبعض المتظاهرين وما ذلك
احتفلت بالفوز على الارجنتين والبرازيل
وكنت سعيد جدا وذهبت الى بلدك وانت سعيد
فلماذا الان قطر هي اللقمه التي تقف هي هي
هي هي هي السبب هي الغيره انا انا اجزم ان
ذلك هو الشيء الرئيسي هم يرون ان قطر تلك
الدوله الصغيره حجما وعددا وسكانا لماذا
تحتفظ بكل هذه الثروات لماذا لا توزعها
على العالم العالم
لماذا انتظروا الماضيه
باعوا لقطر الانديه
وباعوها السلاح ويبيعونها
شركاتهم يبيعون الكثير من الامم
نحن نعلم جميع انه كان هناك ضغوط غربيه من
انجلترا ومن امريكا ومن بعض الدول الغربيه
ولكن لم ينجحوا لم ينجحوا لان قطر رغم همم
صغر حجمها لكنها قويه سياسيه موجوده نسمع
سيدنا
لماذا هذه قطر يغارون منها وهي نفس الدول
التي فتحت همم فتحت دراعيها للاستثمارات
القطريه
بمليارات الدولارات وسماحت بان تشتري قطر
نادي نادي باريس العريق والمرموق يعني
لماذا نظريه المؤامره هذا
يا اخوي العزيز اخوي رفيق الله يعني
في حدوث
الاستثمار والاقتصاد فهي دوله عزيزه ودوله
رائده ودوله مساعده ودوله بتحب الخير
للجميع ولكن لما تستضيف بطوله مثل بطوله
كاس العالم وكل هذا التنظيمات الرائعه
التي سوف يراها ويشاهدها باما اعينهم
بيشهدوها انا استغرب من هذا الهجوم
الحقيقه يعني هو اولا غيره وثانيا لانهم
ليس بيستطاعتهم يعني مسايره قطر في
التنظيم انا اتحدث انا اقول لك وانا من
الاشخاص اللي شاركت في تنظيم دوره الالعاب
الاسيويه شارك في تنظيم بطوله العالم
للالعاب القوى الصالات والخارجيه ف- همم
يعني همم الكلام مردود عليه الصحفي
البريطاني اللي هو الله يسلمك
واكيد اخوي العزيز همم استاذ حميد يعرفه
اللي هو لما قال يا اخي اقول لبعض
اللاعبين من لا تعجبهم قطر فلا يذهب لك
عالم يا اخي هذا الجري اللي نكر مين يكون
على اساس والله يجي ولا ما يجي انا عندي
بيكم عندي ميسي عندي نيمار عندي كل هؤلاء
النجوم فطحلت الكره القدم سوف يتنافسون
التنافس الشريف وفيما يتعلق بالمدرب
الالماني ان شاء الله عمره محتفل ولا راح
يحصل على الكاس لان الكاس رايح الارجنتين
الله يسلمك كلكم تشجعون الارجنتين انا
الوحيد الذي يتمنى على الاقل ان تفوز
فرنسا
وان تحتفظ باللقب بريطانيا
السيد همم سيد همم عبد الله يوسف قد يقول
قائل لماذا لا تستفيد اذا قطر بعد
المونديال ان تعطي مثلا للدول العربيه لا
تحدث عن القريبه منها كل الدول العربيه في
ان تغير من قوانينها في ان همم مثلا نرى
نفس الممارسه التي نشهدها هنا في اوروبا
من حيث
الحقوق
والحريات هي التي همم اقتصاديا ما شاء
الله وصلت الى تجاوزت الدول الدول عريقه
اقتصاديه
وشاهدنا النهضه لعمرانيه في قطر
لماذا لا تكون معها نهضه اخرى
استاذ رفيق قطر تتقدم بخطا يعني يوافق
الخطوه يمشي ملكا اقول لك اياه هذه اغنيه
ام كلثوم ولكن انا اقول لك الحقيقه ان ان
ان قطر ما قدمته بالتغيير في قوانين وقبلت
يعني حصلت على قبول منظمه العمل الدوليه
وحصلت كذلك على يعني البلاستينج من الفيفا
وهكذا من الدول المشاركه في في هذه
المونديال طبعا كلهم طبعا اشاد
يعني حقوق العمال يعني هتستغرب من بعض من
انتخابات اوروبا بتقول والله يا اخي انا
بلبس فانيله مع العمال طيب وين كان هذا
هذا الكلام في دول لهم انا اتحدى اي دوله
من دول التي استضافت كاس العالم ان تمنح
تاشيره
للجمهور بحصول على تذكره وكذلك همم بطاقه
السنه هيا هيا الى قطر فانا اتحدى اي دوله
الدول الاوروبيه وامريكا وغير من الدول
دائما تقف في يعني في وجه ال ال ليس
الجمهور ولكن المنافسين في امريكا مؤخرا
في بطوله العاب القوى يعني استبعد عدد
كبير من نجوم وابطال غانم وابطال افريقيا
ولم تمنعهم التاشيره حتى يتثنى للاعبين من
الولايات المتحده بالفوز بالميداليات وهذا
كان عبء كبير وكان عيب كبير والاتحاد
الدولي للالعاب القوى يعني حطها في سجلات
على الحقيقه بامكانكم ترجعون للمنتخبات
غانا ونيجيريا كلها طبعا لم يمنحوا
التاشيرات بينما قطر مجرد حصولك على تذكره
همم وكذلك بطاقه هيئه فانت مرحب بك في خطر
السيد حميد الكفائي تعتقد انه بعد مونديال
قطر ستتغير الامور تتحسن اكثر
همم تحقق قطر ما حققته اقتصاديا تحقق في
الجوانب الاخرى بالمقارنه مع الدول
العربيه الاخرى باختصار انا اتمنى ان
ترتقي قطر الى المستوى الدولي الى ان تكون
دوله حره دوله فيها حقوق انسان وفيها
رفاهيه والانسان يعامل كاسان ولكن مشكله
كاس العالم الان وهذا المونديال تحديدا
قطر بتقديم رشاوه استقالات بلاتينيوم
وكلاتر محاكمات ما زالت قائمه هذه المشاكل
بلاتيني بلاتيني بلاتيني كان على دوره
لا لا اسمح لي بلاتيني بلاتيني خذي رجله
ولا هذا من ل لبرنامج بلاتر عطالله اوروبا
وليس لقطر
يعني
الله يخليك
ولكن نحن الان نتحدث عن استضافه
شكرا شكرا شكرا
لماذا لا سيد حميد الكفايه الصحفيه والكذب
ااا السياسي كنت معنا من لندن اشكرك يا
سيد عبد الله يوسف همم الملا رئيس نادي
الاهلي اا في قطر سيد محمد منذر كنت اريد
ان اسالك على الفريق الذي تريد ان يفوز
وتقول ارجنتين لكن من تعتقد انه سيفوز في
عليا
فرنسا
حلقه اليوم من نقاش القاكم غدا في نفس
التوقيت
[موسيقى]